moncayo no locali dove entrò e lo fa
bene a tutti
ok bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video sono poi j
oggi siamo qua con giulia che se persona
anche lì a fare video con me oggi
facciamo lo faresti se lo faresti no
spiega allora veramente c'è questo tasso
to schiacci o meno se ti piace la
condizione che il gioco tipo né mamma
mia che ti mette davanti due opzioni no
tipo che sarai una ragazza più di
successo nel mondo ma e poi c'è quella
negativa mori a 30 anni per dire che fai
o vai protesi prendi tutte e due ma a
pensar adesivi attinta dalla patch
italia grazie a dio e madre esisterei
non c m e trovare perché sono stato
tutta la vita inediti che per agnone e
mando le madonne ho messo anche la
traduzione in italiano che traduce di
merda pro traduceva ragazzi la prima
domanda di oggi e sarete in grado di
ripristinare la vostra vita ma dei
pristina la costringa sarebbe che
ripartì da zero
ok grazie ma si inizierà tutto daccapo
in una famiglia diversa in un salto
paese diverso tu lo faresti
no non lo farò mi sento pensa neanche io
lo vorrei che questa brutta e dai cani
capace gameplay ma ci trovi mai casa si
può diventare invisibile in qualsiasi
momento da una madre con mazza 3d
tigrato marino quando si è in visibili
anche tu sei c è con cui da so
invisibile c'è tanto di 500 che si
diceva che cosa invisibile non mi posso
vedere che cosa non l'hanno invisibile
affatto remo posso vedere che ho
invisibile voglio vederti scacchetti
scacco li voglio essere semplicemente
this calcoli o di fran ultimo subito una
cosa hai visto anche se sei visibile
diventa incredibilmente bravo a scrivere
musica ma diventi sorda ecco questo
potrebbe interessante chiedere un
assurdo mia musica
ecco la casacca non lo so sempre dove
aspetta solo di 999 sordo musica per
tanti bidoni mozart ma napoli vita il
cazzo di mozart ma zardetto ghiera a
vista mentre una tutta senza dai 9
rodiano milione caso scotto matt ingari
si potrebbe rallentare il tempo per una
quantità illimitata di tempo ogni volta
che vuoi un po difficile ma se ormai
capita ogni secondo si utilizza uccide
un bambino in africa perché l'africa c4
che in africa pueblo l'africa bene cosa
crudeli sta a noi faremo libero perché
sei tu e lei ma quando ha parecchio da
fare giulia ben presto giallo è
possibile prendere questo pulsante home
ha mai il vostro cane gatto maria subito
sì perché tanto non ci avremmo bella
neanche da tim ionali molto anche tempo
che però schiacciato scusa come a
settembre mostro amis settembre ragazzi
proprio video vi sia piaciuto rottura
rischi comunque ucciso e ha deciso il
tasto le spiace ma settembre lavagna a
beh allora faccia all'anima sua
come ti chiama il mio dane tasto no come
si chiama sia quella b beethoven noi
finisce vola y ma ora è morto per un
motivo porino vuoi che
inizio solo bobby povero nome è morto
per il nuovo cristiano è possibile
ottenerlo paio di jeans direi erogati
nell'arco di ogni male dei brandelli
mare di una dimensione troppo piccola
no anche se faccio le strip gli strip
ora è possibile leggere la mente di una
di un controllo delle persone va bene il
controllo da mentre persona che bello
ogni se sei una ragazza c'era comunque
ogni volta che si usa questo potere sia
una probabilità del 10 per cento di
sviluppare cefalea viene mai di panini
me ma di testa cefalea a grappolo già
scritta stato nanda medico compagne per
al compare dopo 30 minuti stalle vale a
a ben caso non lo fa io sì lo faccio si
può diventare tutto ciò che si possa
immaginare marmori dai 24 ore potresti
essere chiunque ore christina aguilera e
che vorrei essere cristina d'avena
io lo farei per verdi mai rilento dio
non muoio mai [ __ ] il sistema regate
storiche nicchia 3 mag amica stefan
vidor e al suo stupido ma diciamo nomine
di scritto ma incaricato di noci capelli
gli orari è possibile ottenere la
ragazza dei tuoi sogni
la ragazza non ragazzo ma un amico muore
si potrebbe averlo salvato ma di poco
più di 300 italiani in questa frase che
comunque nei miei scritti di alle medie
mattino per nel latte mente piano ma la
ragazza dei migliori video si aiuto dove
sempre bene che ha detto no grazie
leggero profumo pmi dome gran tiro fuma
un sacco altre persone odore lordo a voi
credo che sia la roba che da altre
persone puzzino a da questo succede
comunque spessissimo
ma tu non pubbliche avete mi avrete il
miglior computer del mondo ma è
necessario utilizzare internet explorer
la navigazione grazie veramente tu non
hai capito niente di questa cosa neanche
in italiano nel gergo di internet si
cerca internet explorer è lento per
navigare su internet quindi ha il
miglior computer del mondo ma andavi chi
è un cane che si morde la coda
l'accusa mt singolo farei otterrete un
rapporto con la persona che più vicino
tra tutti gli esseri umani per
soddisfare ogni vostro ideale prossima
domanda di 20 sopra intelligente
facciamoci al 100 il serino è giulia
qualcosa devi prendere seriamente tutto
quello che dice migliaia questa giornata
una merda mi cosmici da tempo di gérard
balcone sul serio però comunque poi pure
controllati diventare super intelligente
questa quando diventerò un make up
precious la nota youness chi lo sa fate
ridere un grissino la voce mi sta però
senza che il traducano da glee ci penso
più che il take pictures with dirai tu
puoi fare delle foto con i fiocchi box
il canale dal team di dio santo hai
fatto inglese non puoi mai cancellarli
dal tuo cervello quindi lo faccio
anch'io mi chiese che figo con un senso
diverso andato milioni di dollari ma la
sua nathalie beneficenza me questo penso
che avrebbero tutti grande giuria per
noi
è possibile trasformare chiunque e in
qualsiasi cosa il tuo volto umano sarà
mostrando che è costato su di essa vi
voglio posso trasformarti in selena
gomez proceda mia faccia
no vuoi diventare invisibile per un
capriccio ogni volta che tu fai che lo
fai rito che si restringe di un
millimetro tranquilla sì che tanto
possiamo respingerli quanto peserà
sempre abbastanza
possiamo concludere questi episodi di lo
faresti è stato molto carino
spero che evidenziamo aiuto ragazzi
concludiamo che l'episodio cose per il
momento è un mi piace anche adesso che
come cristiani a dire velocemente dopo
le scritte iscrivetevi e ci vediamo un
prossimo video sistina con le scritte
rischi per regalare un ottimo video
brava da ragazzi
[Musica]